Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Get groceries delivered across the GTA from real Canadian Superstore with PC Express. Shop online for super prices and super savings. Try it today and get up to $75 in PC Optimum Points. Visit superstore.ca to get started. In a darkly comedic look at motherhood and society's expectations, Academy Award-nominated Amy Adams stars as a passionate artist who puts her career on hold to stay home with
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再次重申，网址是 therestishistory.com。使用 PC Express，从真正的加拿大超级市场（Canadian Superstore）购买杂货，并送货上门，覆盖整个大多伦多地区（GTA）。在线选购，享受超值价格与超省优惠。今天就来体验，还可获取高达 75 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。访问 superstore.ca 即可开始。在这部以黑色幽默视角审视母职与社会期待的影片中，奥斯卡金像奖提名演员艾米·亚当斯饰演一位充满热情的艺术家，她为了照顾
her young son. But her maternal instincts take a wild and surreal turn as she discovers the best, yet fiercest part of herself. Based on the acclaimed novel, Nightbitch is a thought-provoking and wickedly humorous film from Searchlight Pictures. Stream Nightbitch January 24 only on Disney Plus. changed very quickly. Helping make sense of the world when it matters most. Stay in the know. Download the free CBC News app or visit cbcnews.ca. Music We were making our way through the deserted fields looking for stray hens and eggs when a nearby artillery unit opened fire. We went to look and found a battery of Polish gunners
年幼的儿子而暂别职业生涯。然而，随着她发现自己最好但也最凶猛的一面，她的母性本能经历了一场疯狂而超现实的转变。改编自广受好评的小说，《野狗妈妈》（Nightbitch）是一部由探照灯影业（Searchlight Pictures）出品、引人深思且诙谐荒诞的电影。1 月 24 日起，锁定 Disney Plus 独家流媒体首播。局势变化非常快。在至关重要的时刻，帮助理解这个世界。掌握最新资讯。下载免费的 CBC News 应用程序，或访问 cbcnews.ca。音乐我们正穿过荒芜的田野寻找流浪母鸡和鸡蛋，这时附近的一个炮兵部队开火了。我们前去查看，发现了一连波兰炮兵
setting up for a barrage. The gun sight was hidden in a clearing within a large wood. As we watched, suddenly out of the wood came a large bear walking on its hind legs. It seemed to be carrying something. Both Vincent and I shouted a warning to the gunners that a bear was going towards them, but nobody responded. The bear went up to the trail legs of the artillery gun and placed a shell on the ground. The bear then went back into the wood and reappeared with another shell. The bear then went back into the wood and reappeared with another shell. By this time we'd realised that the bear was tame and most likely a circus bear.
正在架设火炮准备进行齐射。炮位隐藏在一处大树林中的空地上。正当我们注视时，突然从树林里出来了一只用后腿走路的大熊。它似乎扛着什么东西。文森特和我双双向炮兵大喊警告，说有一只熊正朝他们走去，但没有人回应。这只熊走到火炮的支架旁，在地上放了一枚炮弹。随后，熊又走回树林里，带着另一枚炮弹重新出现。熊又走回树林里，带着另一枚炮弹重新出现。此时我们已经意识到这只熊是被驯养的，很可能是一只马戏团的熊。
We just went on our way. That was John Clarke and in April 1944 he was serving with a black watch in the Monte Casino campaign, one of the most celebrated campaigns of the Second World War, the battle for Italy. And he is remembering an incident near the village of Aquafondata, which is six miles from Monte Cassino. And he and his comrade Vincent were foraging for food. And that story, Tom, which you have quoted, it's actually quoted by Eileen Orr in her book, Wojtek the Bear, Polish war hero. And as you say in your notes, it's like an armored bear from Philip Pullman's stories. The last episode we were talking about the
我们便径直上路了。刚才那是约翰·克拉克（John Clarke），在 1944 年 4 月，他正随黑卫士兵团（Black Watch）参加卡西诺山战役——这是第二次世界大战中最著名的战役之一，即意大利战役。他正在回忆发生在阿夸方达塔（Aquafondata）村庄附近的一起事件，该村距离卡西诺山有六英里。当时他和战友文森特正在寻找食物。汤姆，你引用的那个故事，实际上是艾琳·奥尔（Eileen Orr）在她的书《波兰战争英雄熊沃伊泰克》（Wojtek the Bear, Polish war hero）中引用的。正如你在笔记中所说，这就像菲利普·普尔曼（Philip Pullman）故事里的装甲熊。在上期节目中，我们谈到了
fate of Poland. We talked a lot about Danzig, Gdansk. There's a brilliant museum of the second world war in Gdansk. And as is my want when I went there with Sanbritt Jr. We went to the shop to look for merch and they didn't have very much I have to say, but what they did have was dozens of copies of a children's book in Polish about this bear, Wojtek, who is an absolute folk hero in Poland, isn't he? And a symbol of Polish resistance and Polish heroism in the second world war. And I think every Polish friend I've got has said, do you know the story of Wojtek?
波兰的命运。我们聊了很多关于但泽、格但斯克的事。格但斯克有一座非常棒的第二次世界大战博物馆。正如我所习惯的那样，我和小桑布里特（Sanbritt Jr.）去那里时，我们去了商店想找找周边商品，我得说他们东西不多，但他们确实有几十本用波兰语写的关于这只熊沃伊泰克的儿童读物。沃伊泰克在波兰绝对是一个民间英雄，对吧？也是二战中波兰抵抗运动和波兰英雄主义的象征。我想我认识的每一个波兰朋友都说过：“你知道沃伊泰克的故事吗？”
So particular shout out if she's listening to this to Pizena, who first mentioned Wojtek to us and in fact gave us a children's book about it. Maybe it was the one that you saw in the shop in Gdansk. And this is about a bear, but important to emphasize that it's about a Polish bear. So in the account that you read about those British officers walking the battlefield of Monte Cassino, the bear is helping Polish gunners and these Polish gunners are fighting on the British side against the Germans. And so in a sense, this is what I said at the end of our previous series that we wanted to give a kind of coda to that story, terribly dark, bleak, sombre
所以，特别向皮泽娜（Pizena）致以谢意（如果她正在听这期节目的的话），她是第一个向我们提起沃伊泰克的人，事实上还送了我们一本关于它的儿童读物。也许就是你在格但斯克商店里看到的那本。这是一个关于熊的故事，但必须要强调的是，这是一只波兰熊。因此，在你读到的那个关于英国军官漫步在卡西诺山战场的记述中，这只熊是在协助波兰炮兵，而这些波兰炮兵正在与英国人并肩作战，共同对抗德国人。所以从某种意义上说，正如我在上一系列节目结束时所说的那样，我们想为那个故事——那个极其黑暗、凄凉、阴郁的
story. But I guess this is also a palate cleanser. It's a way of kind of plunging back into the heart of darkness, but coming out perhaps the other side. And I think, I mean, I don't want to speak for Polish people, maybe they can correct me, but I think that is, that is a huge part of why the incredible story of Wojtek, the bear who basically becomes a Polish soldier, why it has the kind of resonance that it does. So before we come to Woitek, we've also done a number of episodes on famous animals in history. So we've done dogs, we've done monkeys, and we have actually already had a number of bears on The Rest is History. So we did
故事——做一个某种尾声。但我猜这也是一种清口茶。这是一种重新潜入黑暗之心，但或许能从另一面走出来的方式。而且我认为，我的意思是，我不想替波兰人说话，也许他们可以纠正我，但我认为这正是为什么沃伊泰克——这只基本上变成了波兰士兵的熊——那不可思议的故事之所以能产生如此巨大共鸣的很大一部分原因。所以在我们讲到沃伊泰克之前，我们还做过几期关于历史上著名动物的节目。所以我们做过狗，做过猴子，事实上我们在《历史的其余部分》里已经讲过好几只熊了。比如我们做过
an episode on the inauguration of the Colosseum in AD 80, and that featured a bear from Caledonia. There's the polar bear that was given to Henry the third by the king of Norway in 1252 and which was kept in the tower of London. And then there was Lord Byron who kept a bear when he was a student at Trinity. Yeah. Because he'd been, he'd been told he couldn't have a dog. So he, he wrote in his diary, I've got a new friend, the finest in the world. When I brought him here, they asked me what I meant to do with him. And my reply was he should sit for a fellowship.
一期关于公元 80 年罗马斗兽场落成典礼的节目，其中就有一只来自卡利多尼亚（Caledonia）的熊。还有 1252 年挪威国王赠给亨利三世、并被饲养在伦敦塔里的北极熊。然后还有拜伦勋爵（Lord Byron），他在三一学院（Trinity）当学生时养过一只熊。对。因为他被告知不能养狗。所以他在日记里写道：“我交了一个新朋友，世上最好的一位。当我把他带到这里时，他们问我打算拿他怎么办。我的回答是他应该去竞争一个院士名额。”
So Byron and his bear. None of these were military bears. None of these were fighting bears and Wojtek is a fighting bear. Wojtek is a military bear. There are actually other examples of bears who served as mascots in war. Probably the most famous of these is an American black bear who was called Winnipeg. And Winnipeg came into the possession of a guy who originally had come from Birmingham. So he was a Brummie who'd emigrated to Canada and he'd settled
所以拜伦和他的熊。这些都不是军用熊。这些都不是战斗熊，而沃伊泰克是一只战斗熊。沃伊泰克是一只军用熊。事实上，还有其他在战争中担任吉祥物的熊的例子。其中最著名的可能是一只名叫温尼佩グ（Winnipeg）的美国黑熊。温尼佩グ落入了一个最初来自伯明翰的家伙手中。所以他是一个移民到加拿大并定居在
in Winnipeg in Manitoba and there he'd become a vet. And then in 1914, war broke out and the news came to Canada, you know, dominion in the British Empire. So lots of Canadians signed up to fight for king and country. And Harry Colborne, he got the train from Winnipeg to get shipped for Britain. And at a station in Ontario, he got off the platform and there for reasons that are not entirely clear, because it seems quite an odd thing to be for sale, but he gets an orphaned bear cub. And because
曼尼托巴省温尼佩格的布鲁姆人（Brummie），并在那里成为了一名兽医。然后在 1914 年，战争爆发了，消息传到了加拿大——你知道的，大英帝国的自治领。于是许多加拿大人报名参战，为国王和国家而战。哈里·科尔伯恩（Harry Colborne）坐火车从温尼佩格出发，准备乘船前往英国。在安大略省的一个车站，他走下站台，出于某种并非完全清楚的原因——因为这似乎是一件相当奇怪的出售商品——他买到了一只孤儿熊崽。因为
he's already feeling homesick for his native town of Winnipeg, he calls this bear Winnie, takes him, this orphan bear with him to Britain, trains with the Canadian unit that he signed up to. And then in December 1914, he crosses the channel to go and fight on the Western Front. And he can't take this orphan bear with him. So he donates it to the London Zoo. So Winnie becomes one of the star attractions in London Zoo. And Winnie is there the whole way through the first world war and stays there after the first world war. And in 1924, a writer called A. A. Milne, takes his son, who's a little boy called Christopher Robin, to see Winnie this Canadian black bear. And Christopher Robin thinks this bear is wonderful, goes back home and changes the name of his teddy bear from Edward bear to Winnie the Pooh.
他已经开始思念他的故乡温尼佩格，所以他给这只熊取名叫温尼（Winnie），并带着这只孤儿熊一同前往英国，在他报名的加拿大部队里接受训练。然后在 1914 年 12 月，他横渡英吉利海峡，前往西线作战。他不能把这只孤儿熊随身带去，于是把它捐给了伦敦动物园。因此，温尼成了伦敦动物园的明星景点之一。温尼在一战期间一直待在那里，一战结束后也留在了那里。到了 1924 年，一位名叫 A·A·米尔恩（A. A. Milne）的作家带着他名叫克里斯托弗·罗宾（Christopher Robin）的小男孩去看望温尼这只加拿大黑熊。克里斯托弗·罗宾觉得这只熊太棒了，回家后就把他的泰迪熊的名字从爱德华熊（Edward bear）改成了小熊维尼（Winnie the Pooh）。
That's Winnie the Pooh. Winnie the Pooh was this, wow, that's amazing. But the real Winnie the Pooh, as in Winnipeg, never saw action. Is that right? No, doesn't see action. There's a big difference with Wojtek. Okay, so there is another famous bear that does see action, because this is a bear who gets taken up in the Korean War by a US paratrooper unit, and she's bought as a cub from a Japanese zoo, say right at the beginning of the Korean War in 1953. And the paratroopers, you know, they go to Korea and
那就是小熊维尼。小熊维尼竟然是这样，哇，这太神奇了。但真正的维尼，也就是温尼佩格的那只，从未上过战场。是这样吗？是的，它没有上过战场。这与沃伊泰克有很大不同。好吧，所以还有另一只著名的熊确实上过战场，因为这是一只在朝鲜战争初期被一支美国伞兵部队收留的熊，它是在 1953 年朝鲜战争刚开始时从一家日本动物园买下的一只幼崽。伞兵们，你知道的，他们去朝鲜时
they take her up in planes and make her do paratroop jumps. God, that's a shock for a bear. I mean, does she do it? Does she like it? Well, she hates it. I mean, she absolutely hates it. Of course. I mean, you know, you're a bear and you're being chucked out of a plane. Of course you can hate it. And on her second jump, understandably, she's so upset that she starts biting the soldiers as they tried to push her out. And then on her fourth attempt, she actually, she chews up the boot of a soldier, but they keep doing it.
把它带上飞机，让它进行伞兵跳伞。天哪，这对一只熊来说真是个打击。我是说，它真的跳了吗？它喜欢吗？好吧，它恨透了。我是说，它绝对恨透了。当然。我是说，你是一只熊，然后你被从飞机上扔出去。你当然会恨它。在它的第二次跳伞时，可以理解的是，它非常沮丧，以至于当士兵们试图把它推出去时，它开始咬他们。然后在它的第四次尝试中，它竟然把一个士兵的靴子给嚼烂了，但他们还是继续这样做。
They keep chucking her out of the plane with her parachute and she ends up garlanded with honors. So she wins a parachute is bad. She wins a purple heart. She wins a Korean service medal. But I think it's fair to say that she's not an enthusiastic paratrooper. She doesn't enjoy it. And in 1954, so she's only sees a year service, she's discharged and sent to Lincoln Park Zoo in Chicago. So we could have gone
他们继续用降落伞把它从飞机上扔出去，最后它身上挂满了荣誉。所以它赢得了一场——跳伞很糟糕。它赢得了紫心勋章。它赢得了朝鲜服役勋章。但我觉得可以公正地说，它绝不是一个热情的伞兵。它并不喜欢这样。到了 1954 年，也就是它只服役了一年后，它就退役了，并被送往芝加哥的林肯公园动物园（Lincoln Park Zoo）。所以我们在美国时本来可以
to Lincoln Park Zoo when we were in America, couldn't we? We were in Chicago. Yeah, we never did. So those, I guess, are the two bears who serve as mascots and who have kind of won a certain measure of fame. But Wojtek's story is a different order. I think it's the strangest, it's the most moving and it's definitely the most historically resonant of any bear, not just a military bear, but any bear in history. Because Wojtek isn't just a mascot, he's literally enrolled in the Polish army as a private for reasons that will come to.
去林肯公园动物园的，对吧？我们当时在芝加哥。对，我们从来没去过。所以，这两只大概就是作为吉祥物服役并获得了一定名气的熊。但沃伊泰克的经历完全是另一回事。我认为它是所有熊——不仅仅是军用熊，而是历史上任何熊——中最离奇、最感人，也绝对最具历史共鸣的故事。因为沃伊泰克不仅仅是一个吉祥物，由于种种原因，他甚至被正式征召入伍，成为了一名二等兵。
And rises, right? And is promoted. Probably gets promotion to a corporal. There's kind of debate about this, but I think almost certainly becomes a corporal in the Polish army. And the reason that it's a moving story is that Wojtek, who is again, like the two previous bears that we talked about, is bored as a cub. He grows up and he provides an emotional focus for soldiers who had been uprooted from their homeland. Many of them lost their families, had suffered unspeakable traumas, And this bear provided them with a focus for kind of wellsprings of love that perhaps otherwise wouldn't have had a focus. And I think that this is a huge part of why Wojtek is so famous and celebrated in Poland.
并且晋升了，对吧？而且还得到了提拔。很可能晋升为波兰军队的下士。关于这一点还有些争论，但我认为几乎可以肯定他成为了波兰军队的一名下士。这个故事之所以感人，是因为沃伊泰克——它和我们之前谈过的那两只熊一样，也是作为幼崽被买下的——它长大了，并为那些背井离乡的士兵们提供了一个情感寄托。他们中的许多人失去了亲人，遭受了难以言表的创伤，而这只熊为他们提供了一个情感宣泄的焦点，否则这些汹涌的爱意可能无处释放。我认为，这就是为什么沃伊泰克在波兰如此著名和受到颂扬的很大一部分原因。
But I have to say, there's also a personal link for me because as we will find out, Wojtek ends up very close to the banks of the Tweed. Right, where you've got your house. My Scottish estate. Yes. So, I mean, it's kind of mad to say this about a bear, but I think his story really does provide a window onto the kind of the miseries of Polish history in the 1940s. But it is also, it's a kind of charming story at the same time. And it's one that has a, it feels like it has a kind of personal connection to me. So it's a story I've wanted to do for a very, very long time. All right. Let's put it back into the context. Let's pick up in a way from where we ended that series. So
但我必须说，对我来说还有一个个人的联系，因为正如我们将要发现的那样，沃伊泰克的最终归宿离特威德河（Tweed）河岸非常近。没错，就是你买房子的那个地方。我的苏格兰庄园。是的。所以，我的意思是，对一只熊说这种话有点疯狂，但我认为他的故事确实为人们了解 20 世纪 40 年代波兰历史的悲惨境况提供了一个窗口。但与此同时，这也是一个相当迷人的故事。而且它感觉与我有着某种个人的联系。所以我一直非常非常想讲这个故事。好了。让我们把它放回历史背景中。我们接着从我们结束那个系列的地方讲起。所以
Poland was defeated swiftly by the Nazis, Warsaw taken, and then Poland was divided up and Poland vanishes from the map of Europe. But of course, a lot of the Polish army have escaped, haven't they? They crossed the border into Romania. And a lot of Poles who are scattered are determined to continue the struggle, aren't they? They have not yet given up their government in exile and so on. So how does Wojtek sort of fit into that story? Okay, so as you say, Poland is defeated, it's carved up, it vanishes from the map, but there are Poles who want to continue the fight. And basically there are three ways in which Poles are able to do this. And the first, and I guess the most dangerous, is to continue the fight in Poland itself.
波兰被纳粹迅速击败，华沙沦落，随后波兰被瓜分，波兰从欧洲地图上消失了。但当然，波兰军队有很多人逃出来了，不是吗？他们越过边境进入了罗马尼亚。许多流散各地的波兰人决心继续斗争，对吧？他们还没有放弃他们的流亡政府等等。那么沃伊泰克是如何融入这个故事的呢？好的，正如你所说，波兰被击败了，被瓜分了，它从地图上消失了，但有一些波兰人想要继续战斗。基本上，波兰人能够做到这一点有三种途径。第一种，我猜也是最危险的一种，就是在波兰本土继续战斗。
And as you said in the previous episode, the German occupying forces have targeted the Polish elites for complete elimination. And their aim is to reduce the mass of the Polish population to kind of helotage, to the status of the helots that kind of helotage to the status of the helots that the Spartans used as their slave labor. That's what the Germans want to make the Poles become. And so effectively for lots of Polish young men, they feel that resistance, I mean, why wouldn't you resist? Because the alternative is either enslavement or extermination. And this is something that they are kind of facing up to very, very early on. So in April
正如你在上一集中所说，德国占领军将波兰精英阶层列为彻底消灭的目标。他们的目标是将广大波兰民众降为某种奴隶阶层（helotage），降为斯巴达人曾用作奴隶劳工的黑劳士（helots）的地位。这就是德国人想让波兰人变成的样子。因此，对于许多波兰年轻男子来说，他们实际上觉得抵抗——我的意思是，你为什么不抵抗呢？因为唯一的选择要么是被奴役，要么是被灭绝。这是他们很早就不得不面对的事情。所以在 1940 年 4 月，
1940, forced conscription in Germany is introduced. Polish young men are kind of rounded up and taken as slave labor into Germany. And so rather than submit to that, lots of Poles take to the forests. And this is the genesis of the Polish resistance. It's like something out of medieval history. They're centered in the vast woods and forests that spread over much of Poland. And by 1943, the Polish resistance numbers almost half a million, which is by far the largest resistance movement in Nazi occupied Europe. But its ultimate fate is miserable because it's destroyed by the Germans.
德国引入了强制征兵制。波兰年轻男子被围捕并作为奴役劳工带到德国。因此，为了不屈服于此，许多波兰人逃入森林。这就是波兰抵抗运动的起源。这就像中世纪历史中的情节。他们的中心位于蔓延波兰大部分地区的广袤树林和森林中。到 1943 年，波兰抵抗运动的人数接近 50 万，这可以说是纳粹占领下的欧洲规模最大的抵抗运动。但它的最终命运是悲惨的，因为它被德国人摧毁了。
I mean, this kind of, they're embroiled in the Warsaw rising and all that. And then of course, by the Soviets who are invading and who are not friends of the Polish resistance want to see it wiped out. Yeah. That's a terrible story. And I'm sure one day we'll come to that awful story. The other option, if you have managed to get outside Poland, is to continue the fight by signing up perhaps with the French and then after the fall of France with Britain.
我的意思是，这种……他们卷入了华沙起义等等。然后当然，还有正在入侵的苏联人，他们并非波兰抵抗运动的朋友，而是希望将其彻底消灭。是的。这是一个可怕的故事。我相信总有一天我们会讲到那个可怕的故事。另一个选择是，如果你设法逃出了波兰，就可以通过报名参加法国军队，然后在法国沦陷后加入英国军队来继续战斗。
And the Polish forces in Britain come to number almost 80,000. So we talked yesterday about how lots of Polish pilots fight for the RAF in the Battle of Britain, perform heroically. Polish sailors join the Royal Navy. Churchill admires them hugely. I think that they garner a great deal of sympathy in Britain, both for the fate of their country, for the evident heroism with which they're defending Britain. And I suspect a measure of guilt at the failure of Britain to come to Poland's rescue. And these soldiers are stationed, lots of them are stationed in Scotland. They're posted along the eastern Scottish coastline to ward off a possible invasion from Norway. And one of the places where a camp is set up is above the Tweed, just downriver from Berwick. And this camp is called Winfield
在英国的波兰军队人数达到了近 8 万人。所以我们昨天谈到，许多波兰飞行员在不列颠之战中为英国皇家空军（RAF）作战，表现英勇。波兰水兵加入了皇家海军。丘吉尔对他们极其钦佩。我认为他们在英国赢得了极大的同情，不仅因为他们国家的命运，也因为他们保卫英国时表现出的明显英雄主义。我猜这其中还包含着一丝对英国未能救援波兰的内疚感。这些士兵被驻扎在——他们许多人被驻扎在苏格兰。他们被部署在苏格兰东海岸，以抵御可能来自挪威的入侵。建立营地的地方之一就在特威德河上方，就在贝里克（Berwick）下游不远。这个营地被称为温菲尔德
Camp. It's a center for lots of Poles there. So there is, of course, a third reservoir of potential soldiers that is waiting to be tapped on when the Soviet Union enters into alliance with Britain in the wake of Operation Barbarossa, which in turn means that the Poles and the Russians are then fighting on the same side. But before that, the fate of Poles in Soviet-occupied Poland is pretty much as grim as it had been for the Polish elites in Germany because the Soviets want to eliminate them just as much as the Germans do. And you described how in your bravura form, the episode that you did before this, how the Soviet forces had invaded Poland on the 17th of September 1939 in the wake of the Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact. It comes as
营地（Winfield Camp）。那是许多波兰人的中心。当然，还有第三个潜在的士兵蓄水池等待着被开发，那就是当苏联在“巴巴罗萨行动”（Operation Barbarossa）之后与英国结盟时，这意味着波兰人和俄国人现在站在了同一阵线。但在那之前，波兰在苏联占领下的命运几乎和德国波兰精英的命运一样惨淡，因为苏联人也同样急于消灭他们。正如你以高超的水平在之前的节目中所描述的那样，苏联军队在 1939 年 9 月 17 日《莫洛托夫-里宾特洛甫条约》（Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact）签订后入侵了波兰。这给波兰人和西方盟国带来了
a total surprise to the Poles, to the Western Allies. The Polish forces are already disintegrating and this just completes that process. 200,000 prisoners of war are taken, 15,000 of these are officers, and these are taken to three camps in Russia and Ukraine, and then they vanish. And no one is really sure what happens to them. And the truth is only discovered later in the war, in the wake of Operation Barbarossa, when the Germans are invading, going into Russia, into Ukraine. And in the forest called Katyn, they discover the corpses of 5,000 murdered Polish officers. And the Germans, the Germans with supreme hypocrisy, trumpet this as an example of Soviet war crimes, which of course it is, but it ignores the fact that
完全的惊愕。波兰军队已经在大崩解，而这只是完成了那个过程。20 万名战俘被抓，其中 15,000 人是军官，他们被带到俄国和乌克兰的三个营地，然后就消失了。没有人真正确定他们发生了什么。真相直到战争后期才被发现，在“巴巴罗萨行动”之后，当时德国人正在入侵，深入俄国和乌克兰。在一个叫卡廷（Katyn）的森林里，他们发现了 5000 具被谋杀的波兰军官的尸体。德国人——德国人带着无上的虚伪，将此大肆宣扬为苏联战争罪行的例证，当然这确实是，但它忽视了一个事实，那就是
the Germans are doing, committing even worse crimes. And these officers who were found in Katyn, they'd been killed in March 1940 along with all the other Polish officers on Stalin's personal orders. But it's not just, as we said, it's not just the officers who are dispatched. So in February 1940, the Soviet authorities had begun the kind of mass expulsion of the Polish civilian population and the NKVD, which is the kind of the predecessor of the KGB, had begun herding up Polish families, taking them to railway stations, cramming them into cattle wagons, sending them off eastwards towards Siberia. And these are scenes that are very reminiscent of the fate of Jews in occupied Nazi Europe
德国人正在犯下、甚至犯下了更严重的罪行。在卡廷发现的这些军官，是根据斯大林的个人命令，在 1940 年 3 月与其他所有波兰军官一起被杀害的。但正如我们所说，遭到杀害的不仅仅是军官。因此，在 1940 年 2 月，苏联当局已经开始对波兰平民进行某种大规模驱逐，内务人民委员部（NKVD，克格勃的前身）已经开始围捕波兰家庭，把他们带到火车站，塞进闷罐车，向东送往西伯利亚。这些场景非常让人想起纳粹占领下的欧洲犹太人的命运，
who were being rounded up and put in cattle wagons, unheated, women, children, as well as men, no food, no drink, freezing cold. And it's been estimated that by early 1941, about one and a half million Poles have been driven into exile. And that of these by the summer of 1941, between a third and a half of all these Poles who've been deported are dead either from malnutrition or from the cold or from exhaustion or of course from from disease. So it's the same process of genocidal expulsions that you're seeing in Nazi Germany and which are much better known. But then it all changes of course in the summer of 1941 because on the 22nd of June, Hitler
他们被围捕并关进闷罐车里，没有暖气，妇女、儿童以及男人，没有食物，没有水，冰天雪地。据估计，到 1941 年初，大约有 150 万波兰人被驱逐流放。其中到 1941 年夏天，所有这些被流放的波兰人中有三分之一到一半已经死亡，死于营养不良、严寒、精疲力竭，或者当然还有疾病。所以这是与纳粹德国正在发生的一样惨烈的灭绝性驱逐过程，而纳粹的行径要广为人知得多。但随后这一切在 1941 年夏天当然改变了，因为在 6 月 22 日，希特勒
launches Operation Barbarossa and suddenly the Soviet Union goes from being effectively Hitler's ally to Britain's ally. And that changes the whole story for the Poles who are in the Soviet Union. Yes, so there's a Polish government in exile by this point in London, which means that they're unable really to resist British pressure. And Britain wants this Polish government in exile essentially to ally itself to the Soviet Union, which of course is really tough for the Poles to do. I mean, you know, the Soviet Union has dismembered their country, stabbed them in the back, deported millions of their fellow citizens, but they
发动了“巴巴罗萨行动”，苏联突然从希特勒的实质盟友变成了英国的盟友。这彻底改变了身处苏联的波兰人的整个故事。是的，此时在伦敦有一个波兰流亡政府，这意味着他们实际上无力抗拒英国的压力。而英国希望这个波兰流亡政府基本上与苏联结盟，这对于波兰人来说当然非常艰难。我的意思是，你知道的，苏联已经肢解了他们的国家，在背后捅了他们一刀，把数百万同胞流放了，但他们
do it. And one of the reasons that they do it is that they see that this is a way to secure the release of the polls who have been kept prisoner in the Soviet Union. And among these prisoners is one of the very few Polish officers who had been deported to have survived Soviet captivity. And this is a man called Wladyslaw Anders. And he had spent, so he hadn't been taken into a wooden shot. He'd been taken to the Lubyanka, the NKVD prison, and he'd spent months there, kind of horrendous experience of imprisonment.
还是照做了。他们这样做的原因之一是他们看到这是确保释放被关押在苏联的波兰人的一种途径。在这些囚犯中，有一位极少数幸存於苏联关押的被流放的波兰军官。这个人叫瓦迪斯瓦夫·安德斯（Wladyslaw Anders）。他曾被关押——他不是被带到木棚里，而是被带到了内务人民委员部的监狱卢比扬卡（Lubyanka），他在那里度过了几个月，经历了可怕的监禁体验。
But then he's released and initially he thinks if I'm going to carry on the fight against the Germans then I'm going to have to do it with the Red Army. But he realizes very rapidly that Stalin is not going to allow an autonomous Polish military force to assemble in the Soviet Union. The risk in Stalin's opinion is too great. And so therefore Anders starts thinking, well, we should try and get these guys out of the Soviet Union altogether and see if we could maybe fight with the British. And Stalin is also very keen to see the back of them. And so Stalin and Anders agree that Stalin will allow Polish prisoners
但随后他被释放了，起初他认为如果我要继续抗击德国人，那么我将不得不与红军并肩作战。但他很快意识到，斯大林不会允许一支自治的波兰军事力量在苏联境内组装起来。在斯大林看来，风险太大了。因此，安德斯开始思考，嗯，我们应该设法把这些人彻底弄出苏联，看看我们是否可以和英国人一起战斗。而斯大林也非常急于摆脱他们。于是斯大林和安德斯达成一致，斯大林将允许波兰囚犯
to travel down to the Caspian Sea, to sail across the Caspian Sea and land in Iran. And the reason for that is that there is a British military presence in Iran because at this time Iran is under joint Soviet, US and British occupation. And specifically the rendezvous is a port called Palaevi on the Caspian sea that I gather is now called Bandar-e-Anzali. And throughout the spring and summer of 1942, over a hundred thousand poles, and this includes women and children, are ferried across the Caspian Sea. They've traveled all the way across the Soviet Union from the camps that they were being kept in. They've traveled there and they're now being ferried across
前往里海，乘船横渡里海并在伊朗登陆。这样做的原因是，英国在伊朗有军事存在，因为此时的伊朗处于苏联、美国和英国的共同占领之下。具体来说，集合点是里海的一个名为帕拉维（Palaevi）的港口，我收集到的信息说它现在被称为安扎利港（Bandar-e-Anzali）。在 1942 年的整个春夏季节，超过十万名波兰人——其中包括妇女和儿童——被渡轮送过里海。他们一路穿过苏联，从关押他们的营地出发，
the Caspian Sea. And they arrive in Palaevi and they're in a terrible condition. You know, they're hunger ravaged, they're disease-ridden, they're shattered, they've travelled vast, vast distances. And I think British officers looking certainly at the men think, oh God, I mean, how are we ever going to get these people into addition to fight? But the British have brought food, medicine, ambulances, and although lots of Poles do die, there are also lots who then start on the road to recovery. And civilians are sent to camps outside Tehran and Esfahan in Iran.
长途跋涉来到这里，现在正被渡轮送过里海。当他们到达帕拉维时，状况极其糟糕。你知道的，他们饱受饥饿摧残、疾病缠身、精神崩溃，经历了极其漫长的路程。我想英国军官看着这些男人们，心里肯定在想，天哪，我的意思是，我们怎么可能把这些人弄到能上战场的状态呢？但英国人带来了食物、药品、救护车，尽管许多波兰人确实死了，但也有很多人随后踏上了康复之路。平民被送往伊朗德黑兰和伊斯法罕（Esfahan）郊外的营地。
And then they are sorted out and they're sent onwards to various territories within the British Empire. So Australia, New Zealand, Rhodesia, Kenya, and lots of these poles. I mean, actually, they kind of end up settling in these various countries and staying there for good. But the plan for the young men, these poles who have come to join the British to fight the Nazi enemy, the plan for them is to send them from Iran through Iraq to Palestine to train them, to get them ready to join British forces and if needs be to join the fight against Rommel who at the time is kind of advancing across North Africa towards Egypt. And this force of Poles, they
然后他们被分类并被进一步送往大英帝国境内的各个领地。比如澳大利亚、新西兰、罗得西亚、肯尼亚，许多这样的波兰人——事实上，他们最终在这些不同的国家安顿下来并永远留在了那里。但对于这些来到英国加入抗击纳粹敌人行列的年轻波兰男人们来说，计划是将他们从伊朗经伊拉克送到巴勒斯坦去接受训练，让他们准备好加入英国军队，如果需要的话，加入抗击隆美尔（Rommel）的战斗——隆美尔当时正穿过北非向埃及推进。这支波兰部队，他们
can't call it the first Polish Corps because the first Polish Corps is, you know, that's the body of Poles who were stationed in Britain. So they become the second Polish Corps and the nickname that they get given is the Anders Army. Brilliant. I have to say, I've got, I've actually got two different friends who have grandparents, I think, who were involved in that movement of people. So I've got a friend called Matt Kelly, who's a historian, and my friend Anna as well. And they are unbelievable stories. I mean, these people who were deported east from the Polish borderlands, they went to Russia, then crossing the Caspian Sea, going across Iran, going across the Middle East.
不能叫第一波兰军，因为第一波兰军是——你知道的，那是驻扎在英国的波兰人部队。所以他们成为了第二波兰军（second Polish Corps），得到的绰号是安德斯军队（the Anders Army）。太棒了。我得说，我其实有两个不同的朋友，他们的祖父母，我想，都参与了那场人口迁徙。所以我有位朋友叫马特·凯利（Matt Kelly），他是一位历史学家，我的朋友安娜也是。他们的故事简直难以置信。我的意思是，这些人从波兰边境地区向东流放，他们去了俄国，然后横渡里海，穿过伊朗，穿过中东。
And then often people would end up in, some people ended up in Africa. Some people ended up in Britain. I mean, it is mind boggling. It's like something from a science fiction book or something. And so little known in this country, isn't it? Yeah. Although there's actually quite a few people in Britain. You know, there's a kind of Anglo Polish community with roots in this movement
然后人们经常会最终流落到——有些人最终到了非洲。有些人最终到了英国。我的意思是，这太匪夷所思了。这就像科幻小说里的情节一样。而且在这个国家却鲜为人知，不是吗？是的。尽管英国其实有不少人。你知道的，有一个英波社群，其根源就在于这场人口运动，
of people in this mass migration. Yeah. But anyway, it's an incredible story. And this is the point where Wojtek enters the story when the bear finally appears. So how does the bear turn up? I mean, it has the force of a kind of folktale, I think. And as with a folktale, there are various accounts of exactly how Wojtek comes to be a part of this movement of Polish troops to Palestine. But I think the basic outline is clear. So there's a group
在这场大规模移民中。是的。但无论如何，这是一个不可思议的故事。而这正是沃伊泰克登场的时刻，这只熊终于出现了。那么这只熊是怎么出现的呢？我的意思是，这带有某种民间故事的力量，我认为。就像民间故事一样，关于沃伊泰克究竟是如何成为这支前往巴勒斯坦的波兰军队的一部分，有各种各样的说法。但我认为基本的大纲很清晰。有一群
of Polish soldiers, maybe officers, maybe private soldiers, accounts differ. And they're in the wilds outside Tehran. And there they meet a young Iranian boy, and he has a sack tied around his neck. And he opens up the sack and inside it there is a tiny bear cub. And the boy tells the Poles that the mother of this cub had been shot by hunters and the cub had been abandoned and the boy had found it. And it's something that he can sell because it's the customary fate of abandoned cubs to be sold to trainers who will raise them as dancing bears. And it's to be a dancing bear is hideous. I mean,
波兰士兵，也许是军官，也许是列兵，说法不一。他们在德黑兰郊外的荒野中。在那里他们遇到了一个年轻的伊朗男孩，他的脖子上系着一个麻袋。他打开麻袋，里面有一只极小的熊崽。男孩告诉波兰人们，这只幼崽的母亲被猎人击毙了，幼崽被遗弃，被这个男孩发现了。这是他可以卖掉的东西，因为被遗弃的幼崽通常的命运就是被卖给驯兽师，被培养成跳舞的熊。而成为一只跳舞的熊是极其悲惨的。我的意思是，
you're chained, you're kind of whipped, you're prodded, you have a miserable life. So the Poles know this and obviously have a sense of fellow feeling for an animal that has suffered bereavement and faces a terrible future. So they buy it from the boy, probably barter or food or you know, maybe they've got a few coins. Anyway, they come into possession of this bear cub. And what happens next? Various stories. So one story says that this cub is bought by a Polish officer who gives it to the niece of another officer. And this niece is called Irina. And she looks after the cub for three months in the, the civilian transit camp where she's been stationed. And the bear is kind
你被锁上链条，你被鞭打，你被戳刺，你过着痛苦的生活。所以波兰人深知这一点，显然对一个遭受丧亲之痛、面临可怕未来的动物有着同理心。于是他们从男孩那里买下了它，可能是用食物进行易货贸易，或者你知道的，也许他们有一些硬币。总之，他们得到了这只小熊崽。接下来发生了什么？有各种各样的故事。一个故事说，这只幼崽是被一个波兰军官买下的，他把它送给了另一个军官的侄女。这个侄女叫伊丽娜（Irina）。她在自己被驻扎的平民中转营里照顾了这只幼崽三个月。这只熊
of very mischievous, full of fun. It's clearly not a good place for a kind of wild animal to be kept. And so Irina gives it to the army as a mascot. And the bear ends up being given by a lieutenant in Anders' army to Polish soldiers in the second transport company. And these have already reached a base at Ghedera in Palestine. So that's one account, another account, and this is the one you'll get in Eileen Orr's book, which is a wonderful account of Wojtek. And she says that actually it was Polish privates in the second transport company had come into possession with Wojtek right from the beginning that they were the ones who had negotiated with this Iranian
非常调皮，充满活力。显然，那并不是饲养野生动物的好地方。于是伊丽娜把它作为吉祥物送给了军队。这只熊最终被安德斯军队的一名中尉送给了第二运输连的波兰士兵。而他们已经到达了巴勒斯坦的盖代拉（Ghedera）基地。这是其中一种说法；另一种说法——你可以在艾琳·奥尔的书里读到，那是一本关于沃伊泰克的精彩记述——她说，实际上是第二运输连的波兰士兵从一开始就得到了沃伊泰克，他们才是与这个伊朗
boy and that they had kept the bear with them as they traveled to Palestine because they weren't really allowed to have a bear with them. And when to Palestine because they weren't really allowed to have a bear with them. And when the commanding officer is told, we're really sorry, sir, we've got this bear cub. He allows them to keep it because he recognizes that it's really good for their morale, that the soldiers are devoted to the cub and that it's kind of raised their spirits. And it's these guys in the second transport company who give the bear its name, right, which is Wojtek, which is a sort of diminutive of Wojciech,
男孩谈判的人，并且他们在前往巴勒斯坦的旅途中一直把这只熊带在身边，因为他们其实不被允许带一只熊。当指挥官被告知，我们真的很抱歉，长官，我们有这只小熊崽时，他允许他们把它留下来，因为他认识到这对他们的士气非常大有裨益，士兵们对这只幼崽倾注了喜爱，这振奋了他们的精神。正是第二运输连的这群小伙子给这只熊起了名字，对吧，叫做沃伊泰克（Wojtek），这是一个源自沃伊切赫（Wojciech）的昵称，
which is a proper Polish name. So the bear is variously known, I think, by Poles as Wojciech or Wojtek. So Wojciech is the formal, Wojtek is the informal, and it means happy warrior. Right. And in due course, Wojtek grows up to full size. He's absolutely enormous bear. And, um, then another Wojtek joins the company. Um, and so the bear is called big Wojtek and the soldier is called little Vojtek. So his full name is, is, is big Wojtek. But as a carb, uh, Vojtek is given a kind of carer,
这是一个标准的波兰名字。因此，这只熊被波兰人称为沃伊切赫或沃伊泰克。所以沃伊切赫是正式的，沃伊泰克是非正式的，意思是“快乐的战士”。没错。随着时间的推移，沃伊泰克长到了成年体型。他是一只绝对巨大的熊。然后，又有一个叫沃伊泰克的（人）加入了连队。所以这只熊被称为“大沃伊泰克”，而这位士兵被称为“小沃伊泰克”。所以他的全名是——大沃伊泰克。但在作为幼崽的时候，沃伊泰克被指派了一个照顾者，
one of the Polish soldiers in the Second Transport Company. This is a guy called Peter Prendis, and most of the soldiers in Second Transport Company are young, they're kind of teenage or early twenties. But Peter is 46 and he's probably the oldest soldier in the company, and that is why he is given responsibility for the bear. It's thought that he is the guy who will prove the best parent. But actually, the role that Peter plays is not that of a father but of a mother. Daddy bears, I gather, do not bring up their babies. Yeah, they're probably not close to that.
第二运输连的其中一名波兰士兵。这个人叫彼得·普伦迪斯（Peter Prendis），第二运输连的大多数士兵都很年轻，十几岁或二十岁出头。但彼得已经 46 岁了，他可能是连里年龄最大的士兵，正因如此，他被委以照顾这只熊的重任。人们认为他会是被证明最称职的“家长”。但实际上，彼得扮演的角色不是父亲，而是母亲。据我所知，公熊是不会抚养幼崽的。是的，它们可能跟这不沾边。
No, cubs are raised solely by their mothers. And so Peter comes to be nicknamed by his comrades, mummy bear. And I mean, you read the accounts of it and Vojtek, he's a little cub. He might get frightened. He might get scared whenever he does, he runs to Peter and Peter picks him up in his arms and cradles him and cuddles him, gives them his finger for Vojtek to kind of suck on. It's all very sweet. But then gradually, of course, Vojtek starts to grow up and he's a great laugh. Is he? Yeah. Bears are like that though, aren't they?
不，幼崽完全是由母熊抚养的。因此，彼得被他的战友们昵称为“熊妈妈”。我的意思是，你读到相关的记载，沃伊泰克当时还是一只小熊崽。它可能会害怕。每当它感到害怕时，它就会跑向彼得，而彼得会把它抱在怀里，轻抚它、拥抱它，把自己的手指伸进沃伊泰克嘴里让它吮吸。这一切都非常温馨。但随后，逐渐地，当然，沃伊泰克开始长大，而且他是个十足的开心果，对吧？
He loves it. So initially there's great fun and games with a Dalmatian that's owned by the British liaison officer. He's always climbing trees and then finding that he can't climb down. So he just drops down and falls on passing soldiers and it's all great fun. And he's, well, I'm not going to call him a perv because of course he's a bear, but he's very keen on stealing the underwear of Polish female soldiers. So to quote Eileen Orr, the women part of a Polish signals unit were furious because after months of living rough in that isolated camp in the dusty desert, they had only recently taken a rare trip to Tel Aviv to acquire the much cherished underwear. And Peter has to go and get it back. What's he doing with it? What interest does he
它太喜欢了。所以一开始，英国联络官养的一只达尔马提亚狗（Dalmatian）带来了极大的乐趣和游戏。他总是爬上树，然后发现自己爬不下来。于是他就直接跳下来，砸在路过的士兵身上，这全都有趣极了。而且他——好吧，我不会叫他色狼，因为他毕竟是一只熊，但他非常热衷于偷波兰女兵的内衣。引用艾琳·奥尔的话来说：“属于波兰通信部队一部分的女兵们怒不可遏，因为在那个尘土飞扬的沙漠中孤立营地里过着艰苦生活几个月后，她们最近才刚刚难得去了一趟特拉维夫，买下了那些梦寐以求的内衣。”而彼得不得不去把它们拿回来。他拿着内衣干什么呢？他试穿内衣有什么
have trying it on? Who knows? I don't know. The thing he really loves is swimming and this is obviously a problem if you're in a kind of dusty parched land in Palestine. So whenever he finds water, whenever he finds a kind of river or a pond or mud or whatever, he'll kind of roll in it. And the larger he gets, the more his use of water has to be rations, because of course it's a very precious commodity. And so he's always trying to sneak into the shower hut. This is another example of his mischievous nature. And on one occasion he does this and he finds that there's an Arab spy in the corner. So he's cornered. So his reward for this is he gets an extra long shower plus lots of fruit and beer. And beer. So he's tanked up half the time.
兴趣？谁知道呢？我不知道。他真正热爱的是游泳，如果你身处巴勒斯坦那种尘土飞扬、干旱贫瘠的土地上，这显然是个问题。所以每当他找到水，每当他找到一条河、一个池塘、泥地什么的，他就会在里面打滚。他体型长得越大，他对水的消耗就越必须被定量配给，因为这当然是一种非常宝贵的商品。所以他总是试图偷偷溜进淋浴间。这是他调皮本性的另一个例子。有一次他这样做了，结果发现角落里藏着一个阿拉伯间谍。于是他被逼入绝境。作为奖励，他得到了一个超长时间的淋浴，外加大量的水果和啤酒。还有啤酒。所以他有一半时间都是醉醺醺的。
So he loves beer and he loves cigarettes and he loves coffee. The cigarettes have to be lit but he won't smoke them, he eats them. But I think the reason for this is that at no point does it cross Wojtek's mind that he's a bear. He assumes that he is a Polish soldier. I mean, he has no reason to think otherwise. He's been brought up by them. He lives among them. He adopts their habits and he marches with them.
所以他喜欢啤酒，喜欢香烟，还喜欢咖啡。香烟必须点燃，但他不抽，他把它们吃掉。但我认为原因在于，沃伊泰克的脑海里从来没有闪过“自己是一只熊”的念头。他认为自己是一名波兰士兵。我的意思是，他没有理由作其他想法。他是被他们抚养长大的。他生活在他们中间。他采纳了他们的习惯，并与他们一同行军。
He kind of learns to kind of salute. I mean, he does this without being instructed. He just kind of picks up on it. Right. Everyone else is doing it. You do it, right? You do it. And so you can see why he would become a massive, massive favourite, not just with the 22nd Artillery Supply Company as the second transport company has now become. But with the whole of Anders Army, the whole of the second Polish Corps, obviously really, really good for their morale. You can completely see why officers are going, yeah, let's keep this bear. It's good. Well, maybe not if your underwear has been stolen and he's trying to get into the shower with you. Yeah, maybe not. But I think in general, very good for morale. But then in December 1943,
他学会了敬礼。我的意思是，他不需要指导就会做这个。他只是潜移默化地学会了。对吧？其他人都在做。你也做，对吧？你来做。所以你可以理解为什么他会成为一个巨大无比的宠儿，不仅受到第 22 火炮补给连（即现在的第二运输连）的喜爱，而且受到安德斯军队全体、整个第二波兰军的喜爱，这显然对他们的士气大有裨益。你完全可以理解为什么军官们会说：“好吧，留着这只熊吧。这很好。”嗯，也许如果你的内衣被偷了，而且他正试图跟你一起挤进淋浴间时，你就不这么想了。是的，也许未必。但我认为总的来说，对士气非常有益。但随后在 1943 年 12 月，
there is a crisis because Wojtek and his company are moved to Egypt, to Alexandria. And the reason for that is that by this point, Rommel is, you know, he's gone and the British have invaded Sicily and going up Italy and they need the Poles to help them in this terrible war. And the crisis is that soldiers are forbidden to transport pets or mascots. There is no room in the transport ship for such animals. So their solution to this is to draft Wojtek officially into the Polish army as a private. And the British authorities approve this. They stamp Wojtek's military papers. He is now enrolled as a Polish soldier officially. And on the 13th February 1944, Wojtek and his comrades, they're in Alexandria, they board a troop ship
有一场危机，因为沃伊泰克和他的连队被转移到了埃及亚历山大。原因是在这个时候，隆美尔已经走了，英国人已经入侵了西西里岛，正在向意大利挺进，他们需要波兰人在这场可怕的战争中帮助他们。而危机在于，禁止士兵携带宠物或吉祥物。运输船上没有空间容纳此类动物。所以他们的解决方案是，正式将沃伊泰克作为二等兵征入波兰军队。英国当局批准了这一点。他们在沃伊泰克的军事文件上盖了章。他现在正式注册成为一名波兰士兵。1944年2月13日，沃伊泰克和他的战友们在亚历山大登上一艘运兵船
and they set sail westwards across the Mediterranean. And their destination, Dominic, is Taranto and from there, Monte Cassino. Crikey, what a cliffhanger. So let's take a break and we will return with Wojtek's heroism of the battle for Monte Cassino. Crikey, what a cliffhanger. So let's take a break and we will return with Vortex Heroism at the Battle for Monte Cassino. Hi, it's Cathy Kay here from The Rest Is Politics US. We felt at this time as America is heading
他们起航向西横渡地中海。他们的目的地，多米尼克，是塔兰托，从那里去卡西诺山。天哪，真是个悬念。让我们休息一下，回来后将讲述沃伊泰克在卡西诺山战役中的英雄主义。天哪，真是个悬念。让我们休息一下，回来后将讲述沃伊泰克在卡西诺山战役中的英雄主义。嗨，我是来自《政治其余部分美国版》（The Rest Is Politics US）的凯蒂·凯（Cathy Kay）。我们觉得在这个时候，随着美国走向
into the Trump administration that we should look back on one of the darkest moments in recent American history. So we have done just that with a series on Trump's insurrection and his attempts back in 2020 to steal the election from Joe Biden. There was an incitement of an insurrection. They stormed the Capitol. They literally have senators running for their lives. We break it down. We give an hour by hour of all the incidents, the fences smashing, the windows breaking, gunshots firing, Trump supporters smoking joints in statutory hall. Just imagine the bedlam and incredibly some of these people are going to be pardoned by Mr. Trump. And so January 6th, I've never told Cady K this, but January 6th is my birthday.
特朗普政府，我们应该回顾一下美国近代史上最黑暗的时刻之一。所以我们正是这么做的，制作了一个关于特朗普的叛乱以及他在2020年试图从乔·拜登手中窃取选举的系列节目。这是一次煽动叛乱。他们冲进国会大厦。他们甚至让参议员们为了保命而奔跑。我们对此进行了剖析。我们逐小时地梳理了所有的事件，栅栏被砸碎，窗户被打破，枪声响起，特朗普的支持者们在大礼堂里抽着大麻烟。想象一下那种混乱，难以置信的是，其中一些人将获得特朗普先生的特赦。所以1月6日，我从来没有告诉过凯蒂·凯，但1月6日是我的生日。
Okay, tune in and listen. Yeah, that's not the only extraordinary thing about the date of January the 6th, however. I mean, this is why this story in this series is so important and so gripping because so many of these characters are coming back with us today and so much has been forgiven and swept under the carpet and America decided in the election last year that they were going to reinstate Donald Trump. With that, there really is no better time to take a look at these events. To hear more, just search the rest is Politics U.S. wherever you at these events. To hear more, just search the rest is Politics US,
好了，请收听。是的，然而这并不是1月6日这个日期的唯一非凡之处。我的意思是，这就是为什么这个系列中的这个故事如此重要和扣人心弦，因为许多这样的人物今天又和我们在一起了，有太多事情被原谅并被扫到了地毯底下，而美国人在去年的选举中决定他们要让唐纳德·特朗普重新上台。有了这些，真的是没有比现在更好的时间来回顾这些事件了。要了解更多信息，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“政治其余部分美国版”。要了解更多信息，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“政治其余部分美国版”，
wherever you get your podcasts. Here a clip from this mini-series at the end of this week's episode. General Oliver Lees had earmarked the polls for the key role of capturing the Monte Cassino massif. He had sensed a fire and a pride in the belles for the key role of capturing the Monte Cassino massif. He had sensed a fire and a pride in the bellies of the Poles that suggested they might be more willing to take on this toughest of nuts than other units in Eighth Army. Visiting General Wladyslaw Anders, the Polish
无论你在哪里获取播客。在本周节目的最后，收听这个迷镇系列的片段。奥利弗·莱斯（Oliver Lees）将军为波兰人指定了攻占卡西诺山地块的关键任务。他从波兰人的骨子里感受到了一种火热和骄傲，这表明与第八集团军的其他部队相比，他们可能更愿意承担这最难啃的骨头。拜访波兰
corps commander on the 24th of March, Lies coated his proposal in very clear terms that what he was offering would be immeasurably challenging but was also a singular honour and indicative of the respect he had for the general and his men. Anders was well aware that the Abbey had not been taken in two months of bitter fighting and that it had eluded the efforts of battle-hardened and highly experienced troops. I realized that the cost in lives must be heavy," he later wrote. But I realized too the importance of the capture of Monte Cassino to the Allied cause, and most of all to that of Poland. So that was the immortal prose of James Holland, brother of the lesser known Holland podcasting star. And that's
军团指挥官瓦迪斯瓦夫·安德斯（Wladyslaw Anders）将军时，莱斯在3月24日用非常明确的措辞表达了他的提议：他所提供的将是不可估量的巨大挑战，但这也是一项无上的荣誉，表明了他对将军及其部下的尊重。安德斯非常清楚，修道院在两个月的苦战中未能攻克，它避开了饱经战火和经验丰富的军队的努力。“我意识到生命的代价一定很沉重，”他后来写道。“但我也意识到攻占卡西诺山对盟军事业的重要性，最重要的是对波兰事业的重要性。”这就是詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland）不朽的散文，他是那个鲜为人知的霍兰德播客明星的兄弟。那是
from James's book, Casino 44, Five Months of Hell in Italy. And that reminds us actually, Monte Cassino is not just any battle of the Second World War. It is regarded as one of the most difficult because it's the hinge of a German defensive line called the Gustav line and the Allies have to break it to get to Rome. And on the summit of Monte Cassino is this monastery that was founded by St Benedict, Tom. Yes. So one of the most celebrated monasteries in the whole of Latin Christendom founded in AD 529. It had been rebuilt and rebuilt. It kind of had this glorious heyday in the 11th and 12th centuries. 14th century there'd been an earthquake, it had been rebuilt
出自詹姆斯的书《44年的卡西诺：意大利五个月的地狱》。这其实提醒了我们，卡西诺山绝不是第二次世界大战中的普通战役。它被视为最困难的战役之一，因为它是被称为“古斯塔夫防线”的德国防御体系的枢纽，盟军必须突破它才能到达罗马。在卡西诺山的顶峰，就是这座由圣本笃创立的修道院，汤姆。是的。因此，这是整个拉丁基督教世界最著名的修道院之一，建于公元529年。它曾被重建又重建。它在11和12世纪有过一段辉煌的全盛期。14世纪曾发生过地震，它被重建了
again. So it's a great emblem of the ability of the Catholic Church to rise above all the disasters that could be thrown at it. And now it is in the eye of this terrible storm because the allies have to knock it out essentially because the Germans have occupied it and the allies feel that they have to destroy the German positions if they're going to have a hope of breaking through and getting on to Rome. And we actually spoke to my brother in an earlier episode about the buildup to the Battle of Monte Cassino, but Wojtek arrives right in the middle of it as it's kind of reaching this terrible climax. And as you said in my brother's reading, Anders and his army are given
又一次。因此，这是天主教能够凌驾于可能降临其上的所有灾难之上的伟大象征。现在它处于这场可怕风暴的正中央，因为盟军基本上必须摧毁它，因为德国人已经占领了它，盟军觉得如果他们希望突破并继续前进到罗马，他们就必须摧毁德国人的阵地。我们在之前的一集里实际上和我的兄弟谈到了卡西诺山战役的筹备过程，但是沃伊泰克正是在它达到这种可怕高潮的正中间到达的。正如你在我兄弟的朗读中所说的那样，安德斯和他的军队得到了
the opportunity to storm Monte Cassino, to capture it, and you know this is a mark of great honor because as my brother says, it's the toughest of nuts. Um, and there have previously been three attempts to take the monastery. It's failed. The monastery itself has been bombed completely into rubble, which actually means that it's now harder to take because there are more places to kind of hide. Three offensive has failed. The polls will now take part in the fourth offensive operation diadem and in fact will kind of spearhead it. So the task of the Poles is to capture a mountain that has defied all the previous allied troops. They've smashed themselves against it and broken
冲锋卡西诺山、攻占它的机会，你知道这是一个巨大荣誉的标志，正如我兄弟所说，这是最难啃的骨头。嗯，之前已经有过三次夺取修道院的尝试。都失败了。修道院本身已被完全炸成废墟，这实际上意味着现在更难攻克了，因为有更多的地方可以躲藏。三次进攻都失败了。波兰人现在将参加第四次进攻“王权行动”（Operation Diadem），事实上将成为其中的急先锋。因此，波兰人的任务是攻占一座曾让所有此前盟国军队都束手无策的山。他们曾向它发起冲击并在那里撞得粉碎
against it. So can the Poles do it? So 24th of April, 1944, they start moving up the foothills to take up positions for the final assault. And it is the job of Wojtek's company to keep the Polish artillery supplied with shells, with ammunition, as the Poles make their advance towards Monte Casino. So inching forwards. And they do this for three weeks and it's exceedingly perilous and dangerous job. So they are having to drive at night to avoid, you know, enemy artillery, kind of sheer hairpin bends, people always kind of driving off cliffs and things like that. So to quote a Polish veteran who's cited by Elinor in her book, when we finally pulled into the positions of our artillery, we unloaded the ammo and
撞在上面。那么波兰人能做到吗？所以1944年4月24日，他们开始向山麓推进，为最后的攻击占领阵地。沃伊泰克连队的工作是在波兰军队向卡西诺山推进时，为波兰炮兵提供炮弹和弹药补给。所以他们在向前缓慢推进。他们这样做了三个星期，这是一项极其危险的工作。因此，他们不得不夜间开车以避免敌人的炮兵，通过急转弯，人们总是把车开下悬崖之类的事情。用艾莉诺（Elinor）书中所引用的一个波兰老兵的话来说，“当我们最终开进炮兵阵地时，我们卸下了弹药和
fuses and after a short rest turned round and got out as fast as possible. In spite of all our precautions, a number of trucks crashed into the steep gorges killing their drivers. So it's a very perilous business. I mean, this must be absolutely terrifying, traumatizing for Wojtek. I mean, he's just been having larks in the desert, showers and stuff. So this is- Cigarettes. Yeah. So what does he make of all this? Well, he's terrified and he stays in the lorries kind of whimpering, covering his eyes with
引信，在短暂休息后掉头，以最快速度撤离。尽管我们采取了各种防范措施，还是有几辆卡车撞进了陡峭的山沟，司机丧生。”所以这是一件非常危险的事情。我的意思是，这对外沃伊泰克来说绝对是极其可怕和创伤性的。我的意思是，他之前一直在沙漠里玩耍、洗澡什么的。所以这是——香烟。是的。那么他对此作何感想？嗯，他吓坏了，呆在卡车里呜咽着，用
his paws, you know, completely shell shocked. But then he starts to get his, his kind of mojo back and he climbs out of the lorry that he's been hiding in and he kind of looks around and wanders over to a tree and he climbs up the tree and he kind of watches the action. So he's down seeing his friends carting shells up to the guns and carrying crates and things. So he drops down from the tree and he walks over to his fellow soldiers and he holds out his paws to indicate that, you know, he'd quite like to join in the fun. He doesn't really know what it's about, but it's, you know, his friends are doing it. So why wouldn't he want to join in? He's never, of course, been trained to
他的爪子遮住眼睛，完全被炮弹吓傻了。但随后他开始恢复状态，从一直躲藏的卡车里爬出来，四处张望，晃晃悠悠地走到一棵树前，爬上树，观看战斗。所以他下来看到他的朋友们把炮弹推到枪炮旁，搬运板条箱之类东西。于是他从树上跳下来，走向他的战友们，伸出他的爪子，表示他也很想加入其中。他并不太清楚这是怎么回事，但这正是他的朋友们在做的事。所以他为什么不想加入呢？当然，他从未接受过
handle heavy boxes of munitions, but he's a bear. So he's very strong. And so actually he turns out to be absolutely brilliant. And he does this with all his mates and the boast is that he never drops a single shell and he does it kind of for as long as he wants to. And then if he gets bored, he'll go off and maybe have a, you know, have a, have a sleep or something or have a bit of a bit of a dose. Um, and if they want to get him back on, they give him a lit cigarette or bar of chocolate or something, and then he'll join back in. And he puts in really, really sterling work and he contributes to the softening up of the German defenses that that enable Anders' army on the 11th
搬运重型军火箱的训练，但他是一只熊。所以他非常强壮。实际上，事实证明他表现得非常出色。他与所有的伙伴们一起做这件事，人们夸耀说他从未掉落过一枚炮弹，只要他想，他就会一直这样做。然后如果他觉得无聊了，他就会走开，可能去睡个觉什么的，或者打个盹。嗯，如果他们想让他重新开工，就给他一根点燃的香烟或一块巧克力什么的，然后他就会重新加入。他付出了非常非常了不起的努力，为软化德国人的防御做出了贡献，这使得安德斯军队在11日
of May to begin the long-awaited fourth offensive. And it's an absolutely murderous battle. It lasts days and days and days. So just to give a description again from my brother's book, this is just one passage. On one occasion, a Polish Lieutenant had been standing behind three men. A shell came over and exploded right on top of them. He commented, two of the men disappeared into thin air. There was nothing left. But on a bush nearby, I saw the ammunition belt and the stomach of the third. That was all that was left. Soon after he spotted a soldier sitting down close by, simply staring into space. The man was covered in dust and had a glazed expression on his face. The Lieutenant bent over and touched his back and saw that it was covered in blood. The man he realized was dead.
月得以开始酝酿已久的第四次进攻。这是一场绝对残酷的战役。它持续了一天又一天。所以再引用一下我兄弟书中的描述，这只是其中的一个片段。有一次，一名波兰中尉一直站在三个人身后。一枚炮弹飞过来，正好在他们头顶爆炸。他评论说：“其中两个人消失得无影无踪。什么都没剩下。但我在附近的一处灌木丛上，看到了第三个人的弹带和胃。这就是剩下的全部。”不久后，他发现一个士兵就坐在附近，只是茫然地凝视着太空。这个人浑身是灰，脸上带着呆滞的表情。中尉俯下身去摸了摸他的背，发现上面沾满了血。他意识到这个人已经死了。
So, I mean, this is a pretty serious business. And amazingly, I guess partly because he's at the back, right? Because he's helping to load the guns. He's not in the forefront of the action, but he doesn't get hit at all. Am I right? No, he doesn't get hit. So he carries on throughout this. I think, I mean, obviously, if he'd been in the forefront of the battle, it would have been rather different because that is, I mean, really brutal. And on the 17th of May at last, Anders leads the Poles in a second attack on Monte Cassino. The Germans withdraw. 18th of May, the Poles see a white flag flying over the ruins of the monastery. And they're so shattered by
所以，我的意思是，这是一件相当严肃的事情。令人惊异的是，我想部分是因为他在后面，对吧？因为他是在帮忙装填大炮。他不在行动的最前线，但他一点也没有受伤。我说的对吗？不，他没有受伤。所以他在整个过程中一直在坚持。我想，我的意思是，很显然，如果他处于战斗的最前线，情况就会大不相同，因为那真是太残忍了。5月17日，安德斯终于带领波兰人对卡西诺山发动了第二次进攻。德军撤退了。5月18日，波兰人看到一面白旗在修道院的废墟上飘扬。他们被
what they've been going through, but it takes some time to find enough men who are strong enough to go up to the height to take possession of the rubble of the monastery, but they get there and they raise the Polish flag over the scene of desolation and a bugler plays St. Mary's trumpet call, which according to legend had first been played on the walls of Krakow to warn of the Mongols. And so it's hard not to think of all the emotions that must have been felt in Polish breasts, hearing that and thinking of the fate of their own country looking around at the rubble of this ancient monarchy. How this is not a Hollywood film, I do not know. I mean, I don't know how, I mean, Boitek would be an amazing subject. Of course, to a CGI. I mean, I mean, it would be an amazing subject to
经历过的一切击溃了，但花了一些时间才找到足够强壮的人去高处占领修道院的废墟，但他们到达了，并在满目疮痍的景象上升起了波兰国旗，一名号手吹响了圣玛丽的号角，根据传说，这最初是在克拉科夫的城墙上吹响的，用来警告蒙古人。因此，很难不去联想到波兰人听到这些、想到自己国家的命运、环顾这座古老君主国的废墟时，胸中必然涌起的所有情感。怎么这不是一部好莱坞电影，我真不知道。我的意思是，我不知道怎么，沃伊泰克会是一个惊人的题材。当然，对于CGI来说。我的意思是，这对于一个CGI熊来说将是一个惊人的题材，或者我愿意穿熊服演。好吧，去帕丁顿熊那儿。我的意思是，你确实有一种途径。我错过了帕丁顿熊，但我认为沃伊泰克，我生来就是为了扮演这个角色。所以波兰人损失了很多人。第二波兰军团有1150人阵亡。3050人受伤。第22炮兵补给连，也就是沃伊泰克服役的连队，他们蒙受了伤亡。沃伊泰克无疑身处战火之中，但他们做出了英勇的壮举。所以要引用或在卡西诺山战役期间，沃伊泰克的连队为波兰和英国部队供应了大约17,300吨弹药、1200吨燃料和1100吨食物。
a CGI bear or I'd do in a bear suit. Well, it's good to Paddington. I mean, you do have a kind of track. I missed out on Paddington, but I think Wojtek, I was born to play that. So the Poles have lost a lot of men. Second Polish Corps have lost 1,150 killed. 3,050 have been wounded. The 22nd Artillery Supply Company, that's the company that Wojtek's been serving with, they have suffered casualties. Wojtek undoubtedly has been in the line of fire, but they have done heroic work. So to quote or during the Battle of Monte Cassino, Vortex company supplied approximately 17,300 tons of ammunition, 1200 tons of fuel and 1100 tons of food for Polish and British troops.
哦，真了不起。他得到了一个徽章什么的。所以他们都得到了徽章？他们都得到了徽章。所以这是一个印有沃伊泰克扛着炮弹形象的徽章。他看起来就像是要去参军打仗。这成为了第22连的徽章。这是你可能拥有的最具军事纪念意义的物品之一，它成为了第22连的象征。它被不断复制，显然这有助于将沃伊泰克的名声传播到他自己的连队之外。如果沃伊泰克被晋升为下士，这就是发生这一时刻的时刻。我的意思是，这有争议。我想军事记录已经遗失了。所以我们会说他
Oh, good on them. And he gets a badge or something. So they all get the badge? They all get the badge. So it's a badge featuring Vojtek carrying an artillery shell. And he's got, you know, he looks as if he's marching off to go to battle. And this becomes the badge of the 22nd Company. It's kind of one of the most sort of pieces of military memorabilia that you could possibly have. And it becomes the kind of the, I guess, the emblem of the 22nd Company. And it gets copied and copied and it kind of obviously serves to broadcast Wojtek's fame far beyond the limits of his own company. And if Wojtek is promoted to corporal, this is the moment where it happens. I mean, it's contested. I think the military records have been lost. So we will say he
在这个时候被晋升为下士。但这并不是战斗的结束，对吧？我的意思是，对于沃伊泰克来说，因为整个第22连，因为他们仍在意大利艰难地战斗。好吧，他们一直在战斗，直到战争结束的1945年4月。沃伊泰克总是处于核心，不是吗？战争一直持续到波兰人攻占的最后一个城镇博洛尼亚。正如你所说，沃伊泰克在整个战役中一直与他们在一起。而且他确实，你知道，他确实遇到过危险，但这些危险往往不是来自德国子弹。所以他找到了一匹驮马，他认为
gets promoted to corporal at this point. But this isn't the end of the fighting, right? I mean, for Wojtek, because all the 22nd Company, because they're still battling their way through Italy. Well, they end up fighting right up to the end of the war till April 1945. And Wojtek is always in the thick of it, isn't he? The war goes right the way on till Bologna, which is the last town that the Poles capture. And as you say, Wojtek is with them throughout this whole campaign. And he does, you know, he does have kind of brushes with danger, but these tend not to be from German bullets. So he finds a pack horse and he thinks
这太有趣了。于是他悄悄接近驮马并把它逼到角落，驮马猛烈反击，用蹄子踢中了他的脸。这对他造成了一些伤害。也许他离死亡最近的一次是，他漫步到一个由随英国军队服役的印度士兵建立的基地。他走进一个帐篷，和一个锡克教士兵蜷缩在一起，那士兵醒来发现身边躺着一只巨大的熊。他大惊失色，伸手去拿枪，但在杀死它之前意识到这是一只温顺的熊、一只宠物熊。战争结束了，这对第22连来说是个好时光，因为他们驻扎在亚得里亚海。战争结束了。这是夏天。有海滩。所以他们都去了
this is great fun. So he stalks the pack horse and corners it and the pack horse lashes out and kicks him in the face with its hooves. And this does him some damage. And maybe the time he comes closest to death is where he wanders into a base that's been set up by Indian soldiers serving with the British army. And he wanders into a tent and curls up with a Sikh soldier who wakes up and discovers this huge bear lying next to him. And it's so alarmed that he reaches for the gun and realizes that it's a tame bear, a pet bear in time not to kill him. So the war ends and this is a great time for the 22nd Company because they're stationed on the Adriatic. The war is over. It's summer. There's a beach. So they all go down to
海滩。恐怕沃伊泰克再次因调戏女性而有辱斯文。所以他有个恶作剧，他会潜水游向一群毫无防备的妇女。然后他会突然从她们中间浮出水面。有很多尖叫声和水花四溅。沃伊泰克认为这绝对滑稽极了。当然，对于那些随后不得不走过来向意大利女性解释这只熊是谁的波兰士兵来说，你知道，这是结识女孩的好方法。让我向你介绍我的熊。是的。我认为这是形容他是个“辣妹收割机”的一种方式。所以他过得很
the beach. Wojtek again, I'm afraid, disgraces himself with girls. So he has this trick where he swims underwater towards a group of unsuspecting women. And then he'll suddenly surface in the midst of them. And there's lots of kind of screaming and splashing. And Wojtek thinks this is absolutely hilarious. And of course, for the Polish soldiers who then have to come over and explain to the Italian women who this bear is, you know, it's a great way of meeting girls. Let me introduce you to my bear. Yes. He's a babe magnet. I think might be one way to describe him. So he's having a
愉快。他的战友们也过得很愉快，这一切看起来都很棒。但随后当然，斯大林的阴影再次笼罩了他们的前途，因为我们现在已经进入了冷战的爆发期。斯大林不希望与英国并肩作战过的老兵回到波兰，他甚至不希望他们留在欧洲大陆。这一点向英国政府表达了，英国政府说，好吧，我们会，你知道，我们会把他们带回英国。所以他们回到英国，具体来说是回到苏格兰。1946年9月，第22连抵达克莱德赛德。他们游行穿过格拉斯哥的街道。他们被欢呼为英雄，在他们的行列中就有沃伊泰克。而这些士兵现在是
lovely time. His fellow soldiers are having a lovely time, it all looks great. But then of course, the shadow of Stalin falls over their prospects again, because we are now into the onset of the Cold War. And Stalin does not want seasoned soldiers who have fought with the British going back to Poland and he doesn't even want them on the continent of Europe. And this is expressed to the British government and the British government say, okay, well, we will, you know, we'll, we'll, we'll take them back to Britain. So they go back to Britain and specifically they go back to Scotland. And in September 1946, the 22nd Company arrive on Clydeside. They march through the streets of Glasgow. They're cheered as heroes and among their ranks is Wojtek. And these soldiers are now
英国政府的责任。这样做的原因是他们对欠波兰人的债务有着清醒的认识。同样，我认为这是贯穿英国人整个战争态度的东西，那就是一种负罪感。特别是对英国政府而言，这种负罪感当然因为丘吉尔在雅尔塔会议上把波兰出让给斯大林而加剧了。因此，英国对波兰又进行了一次背叛。引用尼尔·阿什森（Neil Aschison）关于英国政府对此感受的话，他们希望通过以慷慨和人道的方式处理波兰武装部队的问题来抚平良心。一个临时的财政部
the responsibility of the British government. And the reason for this is that they're very conscious of the debt they owe the Poles. And again, I think it's this thing that has been shadowing British attitudes throughout the war, which is a feeling of guilt. And for the British government in particular, this guilt is of course compounded by the fact that Churchill has signed Poland over to Stalin at the Yalta conference. So there's been yet another British betrayal of Poland. And to quote Neil Aschison on how the British government feel about this, they hope to soothe their consciences by handling the problem of the Polish armed forces in a generous and humane way. An interim treasury
波兰问题委员会在伦敦政府失去承认后立即成立。也就是整个战争期间一直在伦敦的波兰政府。英国政府在其位置上承认了斯大林在华沙建立的傀儡政府。继续引用阿什森的话，实际上这意味着英国，尽管在经历了近六年的战争后已经精疲力竭且濒临破产，却承担了支付、维持和安置西方波兰武装部队的责任。这其实是一个糟糕的故事，这和战争前夕发生的事情一样糟糕的背叛，因为英国人完全抽掉了波兰流亡政府脚下的地毯。我想他们会说是现实政治，我们别无选择。对于波兰军队，他们基本上想摆脱他们，不是吗？他们真的希望他们都回去。你知道，问题是，斯大林不会把人从这些波兰旅中接回，除非他们自愿回去。换句话说，他们必须是共产主义同情者才能做到这一点。结果，我想只有七名军官回去，大约14,000名士兵选择回去。其中有几个人来自第22
committee for Polish questions was set up immediately after the London government was derecognized. So that's the Polish government that had been in London throughout the war. The British government has recognized the kind of the puppet government that Stalin has set up in Warsaw in their place. So to continue quoting Ashton, in effect, this meant that Britain, although exhausted and bankrupt at the end of nearly six years of war, was taking on the duty to pay and maintain and house the Polish armed forces in the West. It's actually a terrible story this, it's just as bad a betrayal as what happened just
师，他们想把沃伊泰克带走。为此发生了一场大争吵，但第22师的绝大多数士兵选择留在苏格兰，他们得以留下沃伊泰克。指挥官说你不能带走他。相反，他们去了哪里？他们去了温菲尔德营地，那是特威德河上方的营地，离贝里克不远。最初，当地人有一些敌意。他们都遭受配给等问题的困扰，但有两件事我认为有助于缓和关系。首先，同样是人们觉得英国欠波兰人多少东西的那种感觉。
before the war, because the British completely pulled the rug out from under the Polish government in exile. I guess they would say it's royal polity, we have no choice. And with the Polish army, they basically wanted to get rid of them, didn't they? They really hoped they would all just go back. You know, the problem is, is that, that Stalin will not take back people from these, you know, these Polish brigades unless they actively volunteer to go back. So in other words, they have to be communist sympathizers to do it. And in the event, I think only seven officers go back, something like 14,000 privates opt to head back. There are a few of these from the 22nd
其次，第22师有这只熊。沃伊泰克是那种完美的特使，因为他依然像以往一样随和、充满乐趣。他身边还有彼得，你知道，就像熊妈妈一样。他所有的伙伴都在。是的。我想他从来没想过自己不是他们中的一员。在他自己看来，他是波兰人，而不是熊。绝对是这样。所以他们带他去跳舞。嗯，当他去那里时，沃伊泰克让当地儿童骑在他的背上。他通过
division and they want to take Vojtek with them. And there's a massive row about this, but the vast majority of soldiers from the 22nd division opt to stay in Scotland and they get to keep Vojtek. The commanding officer says you cannot take him. And instead, where do they go? They go to Winfield Camp, which is the camp above the Tweed, just down from Berwick. And initially there is some hostility from the locals. They're all suffering from rationing and things, but there are two things that help, I think, to thaw the relations. And the first is, again, that's this sense of how much people in Britain owe the polls.
放巨响的屁来逗他们开心。他们都觉得这滑稽极了。同样，这也打破了与当地女孩的坚冰。沃伊泰克被带到特威德河游泳。所以他被从营地带下来，系着链子牵着，因为他们不能冒他被冲进北海的风险。他在建于1822年的这座美妙的桥——联合大桥下面游泳。这是世界上最古老的仍在使用的悬索桥。他在桥下进行了一次美妙的游泳。嗯，我实际上去参观了营地，沃伊泰克呆过的营地遗址。那里有一个大水池，你知道沃伊泰克有多喜欢水池，周围都是树，上面仍然刻着
And the second is that the 22nd division have this bear. And Wojtek is the kind of perfect ambassador because he remains as amiable and as full of fun as ever. He's still got Peter with him, you know, so kind of mummy bear. He's got all his mates. Yeah. And I think it just, it never crosses his mind that he's not one of them. He's a, in his own mind, he's a pole, not a bear. Absolutely. And so they take him to dances. Um, and when he goes there, Vojtek gives the local children rides on his back. He amuses
他的爪印。我只想向莉维（Livy）致意，我知道她会在听这个，她带我们去了那里，给我们看了树在哪里。活树上沃伊泰克的爪印。这真是一件美妙的事情。这太奇怪了。正如我所说，这是一个以你周一描述的所有黑暗和恐怖开始的故事。然而，有一条纽带把我们带到了特威德河上方的一棵树上，上面刻着一只熊的爪印。人们喜欢他吗？他们很高兴。他们认为他是一个了不起的人。他们确实喜欢。这方面的衡量标准当然是，你知道，此时实行非常严格的配给。而沃伊泰克是一只胃口极大的熊。不仅仅是波兰人，
them by doing huge farts. They all find this hilarious. Again, kind of breaks ice with the local girls. Wojtek is taken swimming in the tweed. So he's brought down from the camp and he's led on a chain because they can't risk him being kind of swept out into the North sea. And he goes swimming beneath the union bridge, which is this wonderful bridge built in 1822. It's the oldest functioning suspension bridge anywhere in the world. And has a wonderful swim beneath it. Um, and I've actually been to see the camp, the site of the camp where Wojtek stayed. Uh, and there's a big pool there and you know how much Wojtek likes pools and all around it are trees and they're still marked with
所有的当地人聚在一起，确保他有足够的食物。也许这有帮助的是在远岸，也就是苏格兰特威德河对面的英格兰岸边，在霍恩克利夫（Horncliffe）村有一个养蜂场，那里的蜂蜜非常好。同样，向他们致敬。所以他们能够让沃伊泰克吃饱。你真的无法杜撰出这样的事。但随后，多米尼克，我的意思是，你知道，这个感人的故事，但接着就是悲剧。噢，不。
his claw marks. And I just want to give a shout out to Livy, who I know will be listening to this, who took us up there and showed us where the trees were. The paw marks of Wojtek on the living tree. It's a kind of wonderful thing. And it's so odd. This is a story, as I said, begins with all of this darkness and horror that you were describing on Monday. And yet there was a link that takes us to a tree above the tweed that is marked with the claw marks of a bear. And the people love him, do they? They're delighted. They think he's a tremendous person. They do. And the measure of this is of course that, you know, there's very strict rationing at this point. And Wojtek is a bear with a huge appetite. And it's not just the poles,
因为在1947年，第22师开始复员。所以他们在全英国找到了住处。营地将被关闭。男人们开始过平民生活，问题是沃伊泰克会怎么样？他找不到工作，卡尼。我的意思是，他找不到工作，你知道，他不能与亲人团聚，因为他的母亲已经死了，真是个大问题。所以决定将他带到爱丁堡动物园。1947年11月15日，你知道，他被装进一个笼子里，笼子放在卡车后面，被车拉到了爱丁堡。嗯，这真是挺让人难过的。
it's all the locals kind of, you know, they get together and they make sure that he has enough food. And maybe it helps that on the far bank, so on the English bank opposite the Scottish side of the Tweed, there is a honey farm in the village of Horncliffe, which is excellent. And again, a shout out to them. So they're able to keep Wojtek in. You genuinely could not make that up. But then, Dominic, I mean, you know, this heartwarming story, but then tragedy. Oh no.
每个看着他离开第22师的人都心碎欲绝，尤其是彼得。从那一刻起，据说如果有人向他提起沃伊泰克的名字，他就会泪流满面。他的战友们也同样悲痛欲绝。他们一再前往动物园。我想汤姆，如果你试图给这个故事赋予一点深刻性，倒不是说它需要，你可能会说，这有一种，这是波兰故事的缩影。人们与家人失去了联系。波兰的每个家庭都饱受悲伤、失落和创伤的折磨。
Because in 1947, the 22nd division start to be de-mobbed. So they are, they're found settlement across Britain. Um, the camp is going to be closed down. The men leave for civilian life. Um, and the question is what is going to happen to Wojtek? He can't get a job Kenny. I mean, he can't get his job, you know, he can't be reunited with his loved ones because his mother's dead, you know, real problem. So it's decided that he will be taken to Edinburgh Zoo. And on the 15th of November, 1947, you know, he's loaded into a cage, the cage is put on the back of a truck and he's driven off to Edinburgh. Well, that is quite sad.
在某种程度上，彼得失去了与沃伊泰克的联系。他失去了他的家人，现在他又失去了沃伊泰克。是的。这是更大故事的一部分。这就是为什么曾是他的战友的波兰士兵总是去看望他，有时他们会闯入他的围栏，像过去的好日子一样和他摔跤。当他们离开时，沃伊泰克试图从栏杆爬出去，不仅仅是波兰人感受到了这种悲剧。我的意思是，爱丁堡动物园的园长，一个叫托马斯·吉莱斯皮（Thomas Gillespie）的人，我的意思是，
And everyone who watches him go in 22nd division is devastated, none more so than Peter. And from this point on it he said that if anyone ever mentioned Wojtek's name to him he would burst into tears. And his comrades as well are devastated. They are repeatedly making trips to the zoo. And I suppose Tommy if you were trying to sort of give this story a bit of profundity, not that it needs it, you might say, there's a kind of, this is Poland's story of microcosm. People have lost touch with their families. Every family in Poland has been scarred by grief and loss and trauma.
他写道：“我从未对看到一只曾享有如此多自由和乐趣的动物被关进笼子里感到如此难过。”这个故事中还是有一线光明的。其中之一是，失去家人的彼得与他们大部分人团聚了。他的两个大儿子永远失踪了，但他的其余家人确实来伦敦和他团聚了。没错。而且沃伊泰克也不是完全陷入痛苦，因为我很高兴地说他变得
And in a way, Piotr having lost touch with Wojtek. He lost his family and now he's losing Wojtek. Yeah. It's part of a bigger story. And that is why genuinely the Polish soldiers who'd been his comrades are always visiting him and sometimes they'll break into his enclosure and wrestle with him like in the good old days. And when they leave Wojtek tries to clamber out through the bars and it's not just the Poles who feel the tragedy of this. I mean, so the director of Edinburgh Zoo, who's a guy called Thomas Gillespie, I mean,
对企鹅着迷。所以他对它们产生了极大的兴趣，每当它们列队走过时，他都会全神贯注地看着它们。当然，波兰人也继续来看望他。不仅仅是他的前战友，因为此时，沃伊泰克已经成为英国波兰人经历过的一切的象征。所以他们会来看他并与他说话。他总是精神一振。这是一个开始在英国引起共鸣的故事，特别是，我认为在苏格兰，在边境地区
he wrote, I never felt so sorry to see an animal that had enjoyed so much freedom and fun confined to a cage. There are shards of light in this story. So one is that Peter, who had lost his family, he is reunited with most of them. His two older sons are lost for good, but the rest of his family, they do come and join him in London. Right. And Wojtek also, it's not total misery because I'm very happy to say that he becomes obsessed
和在爱丁堡，以至于最终沃伊泰克经常出现在《蓝色彼得》（Blue Peter）节目中。儿童电视节目。儿童电视节目。所以他是一个常规明星，但到了他生命的晚期。进入60年代后，他确实开始变得非常沮丧。他陷入了严重的消沉，在1963年11月15日。当时他在动物园已经待了16年。他被实施了安乐死。
by penguins. So he takes a huge interest in them and whenever they kind of march past, he'll watch them with huge fascination. And also of course, Poles continue to visit him. And it's not just his, it's not just his former comrades, because by now, Wojtek has become an emblem for Poles in Britain of everything that they've been through. And so they will come and watch and talk to him. And he always perks up. And this is a story that starts to get resonance in Britain as well, particularly, I think, in Scotland, in the borders region
哦，可怜的沃伊泰克。可怜的沃伊泰克。这是一个苦乐参半的故事，我想是的，对吧，汤姆？是的。所以我觉得，他是一个值得我们播客一集的值得纪念的英雄。绝对是的。播客。而且我认为原因有很多。我们已经讨论过这是一个跨越广阔地域的故事。它始于波兰，带我们去西伯利亚，去中东，去意大利，去我苏格兰庄园上方的树林。它提醒你第二次世界大战是一场多么广泛的世界大战。我认为沃伊泰克也是一个非常感人的象征
and in Edinburgh, to the extent that ultimately Vojtek is always appearing on Blue Peter. The children's TV program. Children's TV program. So he's a, he's a kind of a regular star, but towards the end of his life. So going into the sixties, he does start to become very depressed. He goes into a steep decline and on the 15th of November, 1963. So he's by which point he's been in the zoo for 16 years. He's put down.
波兰与苏格兰友谊的象征。所以我知道他在波兰非常有名，但在边境地区也相当有名。那里的学童对他了如指掌。邓斯（Dunns）有他的雕像，就在特威德河上方。爱丁堡也有一座雕像纪念他的存在。但我认为最重要的是，为什么将这个作为我们在前三集中讲述的可怕故事的尾声是件好事，那就是沃伊泰克的
Oh, poor Wojtek. Poor Wojtek. It's a bittersweet story, I suppose, isn't it Tom? Yeah. So I think that, that, that he is a worthy hero for an episode of, of, of our podcast. Definitely is. podcast. And I think it for a number of reasons. So we've talked about how this is a story that spans a vast range of places. So it begins in Poland, it takes us to Siberia, to the Middle East, to Italy, to the woods above my Scottish estate. It reminds you just how much of a world war the Second World War was. I think also Wojtek is a very moving symbol
经历确实与战争中压倒波兰的恐怖紧密相关。但因为他对这一切完全无辜，一无所知，他不知何故似乎为陪伴他的波兰人提供了一种方式，让他们能够凝视自己悲伤的深渊，凝视他们所失去的一切、他们的丧亲之痛，这种方式比直接凝视黑暗之心要不那么痛苦。我认为这说得通。我的意思是，再次声明，我不想把想法强加给经历过这一切的波兰士兵，但这就是我从阅读中得到的感受，关于他们与这种无辜动物之间显然非常深厚的羁绊。是的。我的意思是，他们失去了一切。他们失去了家人，失去了祖国
of Polish-Scottish friendship. So I know that he is hugely famous in Poland, but he's pretty well known on the borders as well. School children there know all about him. There's a statue of him in Dunns, which is just up from the Tweed. And there's a statue in Edinburgh commemorating his presence there. But I think above all, and the reason why it's good to have this as a coda to the terrible story that we've been telling in our previous three episodes is that Wojciech's
他们可以将许多这种情感倾注在与这只你所说的无辜熊的关系中。这无疑就是为什么这些痛失亲人、思乡情切、悲伤的男人们一开始会收留他。这也是为什么波兰军官说，好的，留着他吧。这也是为什么英国高级指挥官认识到这一点并说，好的，我们会，你知道，将他招募为二等兵。而且我认为，这就是为什么直到今天，沃伊泰克在波兰依然深受喜爱。好吧，汤姆，太棒了。这是一个精彩的故事，非常感人的故事。事实上，我没想到会是一个这么感人的故事。
career does kind of rub up against the horrors that overwhelm Poland in the war. But because he was wholly innocent of them, knew nothing of them, he somehow seemed to provide the poles who were with him with a way of kind of staring into the abyss of their own grief and everything that they'd lost their bereavement in a way that was kind of less painful than staring into that heart of darkness directly. I think that makes sense. I mean, again, I don't want to kind of put words into the Polish soldiers who went through all that, but that's the sense that I get from reading about the obviously very profound bomb that they felt with this kind of this innocent animal. Yeah. I mean, they've lost everything. They've lost their families, they've lost their homeland
我发现这是一个非常感人的故事。这简直是1939年波兰沦陷那个残酷故事的完美尾声。这就是熊沃伊泰克的故事。如果你是波兰人，当然，有很多儿童书可以查阅。向那本关于波兰在二战中经历的最了不起的书致敬，我们谈论了很多，那是哈利·库尚斯基（Halik Kochanski）的书《未屈服之鹰》（The Eagle Unbowed）。但下周我们将带着完全不同的内容回来，因为我听到一个传言，说苏维托尼乌斯（Suetonius）的《十二凯帝传》（The Twelve Caesars）之前的翻译已经被超越了。
and they can pour a lot of that emotion into their relationship with this, as you said, this innocent bear. And that is surely why these bereaved, homesick, grieving men had adopted him in the first place. It's why the Polish officer said, yes, let's keep him. It's why the British High Command recognized this and said, yes, we will, you know, take, enroll him as a private. And I, it's, it's why they invested such love in him. And I think it's why to this day in Poland, Wojtek does remain kind of very loved. Well, Tom, that was amazing. A brilliant story, very moving story. Actually, I didn't expect it to be such a moving story.
是这样的吗，汤姆？我没听错吧？这不由我来说，多米尼克。一位不知名的作者对苏维托尼乌斯的《十二凯帝传》的新译本即将上架，为了庆祝这一点，作者本人将在他的播客中带我们进入一个关于恺撒们的性秘密的系列节目，我们将不仅探讨苏维托尼乌斯自己的《十二凯帝传》，还将探讨提比略、卡利古拉和克劳狄乌斯的生平。因此，下周当我们带着罗马人回归时，这将是一个风格完全的转变，我猜播客的风格会稍微更加淫荡一些。
I find it a really moving story. And it was the perfect coda to the grim story of the fall of Poland in 1939. So that's the story of Wojciech the Bear. If you're Polish, of course, there are loads of children's books you can look that up in. And a shout out to the most amazing book on Poland's experience in the Second World War, which we talked about a lot, which is Halik Kuchanski's book, The Eagle Unbowed. But next week we will be back with something completely different because I've heard a rumor that the previous translations of Suetonius' The Twelve Caesars have been superseded.
带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，非常感谢你。这绝对太精彩了，我们下次见。再见。这里是我们的关于特朗普叛乱的迷镇系列的片段。这些参议员们被引导穿过一条非常狭窄的走廊。其中一个人说，我们距离暴徒只有20英尺。如果暴徒刚好朝另一个方向看，看到一大群参议员走出来，谁知道会发生什么？谁知道迈克·彭斯会发生什么？
Is that correct, Tom? Am I right in hearing it? It's not for me to say, Dominic. That a new translation by an unknown author of Suetonius' The Twelve Caesars is about to hit the bookshelves and to celebrate this the author himself on his podcast will be taking us into a series on the sex secrets of the Caesars and we'll be looking not just at Suetonius's 12 Caesars itself, but also at the lives of Tiberius, Caligula and Claudius. So a complete change of tone and I suspect a slightly more lubricious style
我认为指出这一点很重要，那就是唐纳德·特朗普收到了这些报告却毫不在乎。参议院在下午2点18分被疏散。南希·佩洛西（Nancy Pelosi）也被国会警察从椅子上拉下来，带离讲台，送往西南华盛顿麦克奈尔堡（Fort McNair）的一个安全地点。她最初试图留下来。她不想离开大楼，但出于安全考虑，她不得不离开那里。国会的一位民主党成员此时意识到暴徒开始突破他们的区域，
of podcasting next week when we return with the Romans. So on that bombshell, Tom, thank you so much. That was absolutely wonderful and we'll see you all next time. Bye bye. Here is that clip from our mini series on Trump's insurrection. And these senators are being kind of ushered out through a very narrow corridor. And one of them says, we were 20 feet away from the rioters. If the rioters had just looked the other way and seen that a whole bunch of senators were coming out, who knows what would have happened? Who knows what could have happened to Mike Pence?
国会的一位民主党成员对共和党人喊道，这是因为你们。议员们正在收到短信。这就是他们知道情况很糟的原因，因为他们收到家人的短信说，你在那里做什么？你为什么还没走？你安全吗？但他们没有电视。他们没有看。
And I think it is important to point out that Donald Trump was getting these reports and did not care. The Senate has been evacuated at 2 18 PM. Nancy Pelosi is also pulled out of her chair by the Capitol police and taken off the podium and taken to a safe location at Fort McNair in Southwest Washington. She originally tried to stay. She didn't want to leave the building, but because of security, she had to get out of there. One of the Democratic members of the Congress at this point, as they realized that the rioters are starting to breach their area,
他们试图继续处理当天的事务。我的意思是，这太超现实了。我一直在想，议会内部试图照常营业，而几步之外，暴徒却在那里说他们想把其中一些人绞死，他们想推翻选举结果，这有多么超现实。就在那几分钟后，众议院大厅在暴徒面前被疏散了。警察再次设法在暴徒中开辟了一条非常狭窄的通道，把他们弄出去。
one of the Democratic members of the Congress yells down to the Republicans, this is because of you. And the members are getting texts. This is how they know that things are bad because they're getting texts from their family saying, what are you doing there? Why haven't you left? Are you safe? But they haven't got a television. They're not watching it.
事后有一位议员说，我能看着那些警官的眼睛，我看到了恐惧。他们知道警官们寡不敌众。要了解更多信息，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“政治其余部分美国版”。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子发表评论。
They're trying to get on with the business of the day. I mean, it's this surreal. I keep thinking how surreal it was that inside the chambers, they're trying to do business as usual and feet away, the rioters are there saying that they want to have some of these people hung and that they want to overturn the election result. So then a few minutes after that, the house floor is evacuated literally in front of the rioters. The police manage again to secure a very narrow passageway through the rioters to get them out.
他们试图继续处理当天的事务。我的意思是，这一切是如此超现实。我一直在想，议会大厅里的人们试图照常处理事务，而几英尺外，暴徒们却在那里说他们想把其中一些人绞死，他们想推翻选举结果，这是多么超现实。因此，在那之后的几分钟里，众议院大厅里的议员们实际上就在暴徒面前被疏散了。警察再次设法在暴徒中开辟了一条非常狭窄的通道，把他们护送出去。
And one member afterwards says, I could look in the eyes of those officers and I saw the fear. They knew that the officers were outnumbered. To hear more, search the rest is politics US wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一位议员事后说，我能看到那些警官的眼睛，我看到了恐惧。他们知道警官们寡不敌众。想了解更多信息，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“the rest is politics US”。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。